So to make this a little
bit more formal,
we're going to specify sort
of all the elements in HMM.
You've already sort of seen them.
N is going to be the number of states,
so S1 through SN is our set of states.
So that's like sunny, rainy, snowy.
And then there is a notion of
a state sequence written as Q.
And the idea is that Q sub i is
whatever state I'm at at time i, okay?
So when I say Q sub 3 equals S2,
what that means is at time step 3,
I'm in the second state, all right?
Given the state I can talk about
the full specification of an HMM.
And for whatever reason,
HMMs are referred to as lambda.
It's a triplet made up of three
components that you've all ready seen.
There's a state transition matrix, those
are the A's, the probability of going
from one state at one time,
given that you were at another state.
There's the observation matrix,
which before,
I was showing you as a discreet, and
was actually represented as a matrix.
There's also a continuous
version where your output is
you have a distribution over some
future vector for each state.
So maybe it's you know, you're out
putting a, some sort of a measurement.
And what you say is I've got one
Gaussian in state 1, and a different
Gaussian in state 2, and a different,
different Gaussian in state 3.
The idea is that for any given output,
you can talk about the likelihood or
the probability of given that output,
given that you were in
a particular state.
And then the last thing you need is
that initial distribution pi, right?
because it says, what's
the probability of starting at each,
in a particular state?